recently our cultural authority figures
the people who decide what we're
supposed to think and what we're
supposed to do and what our values and
goals and aspirations are supposed to be
have become very alarmed by a perverse
and dangerous new trend among young
women in particular
of course um I'm not talking about the
trend where young women have their
breasts removed and then start injecting
themselves with testosterone so that
their hair falls out and they grow
beards and they become infertile The
Gatekeepers are not concerned about that
Trend at all if anything they're worried
that the trend isn't even more popular
than it already is
no instead they're deeply worried about
women who choose the so-called Trad wife
lifestyle over the past couple of years
a growing number of women have started
posting Tick Tock videos describing and
documenting their day-to-day existence
as Trad wives quote unquote what is a
Trad wife well she is a woman who stays
home to take care of the house takes
care of the children while her husband
goes to work she she does most of the
cooking and the cleaning she handles the
Lion's Share of the domestic labor while
relying on her husband to be the
provider in breadwinner in other words
she is uh just a normal woman doing what
many millions of other normal women have
done before her
which is why my only objection really to
the Trad wife trend is that we're
calling it a trend and we're giving it a
cutesy name and a hashtag that that's my
only problem with it my wife would fit
the description of a quote-unquote Trad
wife but not because she's taking part
in a Tick-Tock Trend we've been living
this way for 10 years and I wouldn't
really call it a lifestyle either but
rather um a system
that works for us just as it has worked
for the majority of families all over
the world since the dawn of human
civilization even before the Industrial
Age and the Advent of the modern nine to
five job
um you know before that you the phrase
or the term stay-at-home mom didn't
didn't exist still even then most
families featured a man who would go out
whether to the fields to farm or the
forest to hunt or later to the office to
earn a paycheck and a woman who stays in
the home to care for the children
there's a very standard arrangement
the women on Tick Tock aren't inventing
a trend but rather they're partaking in
a way of life that is ancient and
enduring and battle tested
but that's not how the left sees it as
an article on foxnews.com reports quote
donning elaborate dresses fascinating uh
in apron around their waist and popping
in their finest pearl earrings or at
least some iteration of pearls for
another round of household chores or
cooking more and more young women are
following in the footsteps of the
quintessential mid-century housewife
thanks to the latest Tick Tock Trend but
while some women are eager to shirk all
the hustle and bustle of today's
corporate world and channel Barbara
Billingsley as June Cleaver others are
none too happy with the trend quote the
new trend for submissive women has a
dark heart in history reads one headline
from the guardian an article from hype
Bay slapped the videos as disturbing
writing that they quote typically
feature a cyst right CIS straight white
woman longing for the 50s an era where
some women could opt out of
participating in the corporate working
world and be stay-at-home mothers
instead and a third from grazia magazine
accused the trend of quote romanticizing
an era where sexism and racism ruled
we can also add a recent CNN article
which calls Trad wives otherwise known
as Housewives or stay-at-home moms a
quote Fringe subculture
meanwhile a piece by Insider says that
many of these women are promoting white
supremacist views
this was the argument made this week in
a video by a left-wing media
organization called Novara media a woman
named Ash sakhar argues that Trad wives
are really just agents of a far-right
political agenda here she is
though the idea of women being confined
to the home while men do things like go
outside and work isn't exactly new the
image of 1950s Suburban Domesticity has
been given a new lease of Life by the
gals on Tick Tock can you imagine me the
wife of that foolish brainless
some younger Millennials and Zoomers
have decided to embrace living la Vida
casserole dedicating themselves to
cooking cleaning and child rearing while
their husbands or boyfriends I don't
know chop firewood or go to their job in
human resources and look I'm not saying
there's anything inherently degrading
about being a mom or making nice meals I
like cooking elaborate dinners for that
matter my boyfriend does too but the
Trad wife Trend isn't just a way to talk
about the experience of being a woman
and doing domestic labor
it's saying that being a woman or
expressing your femininity most fully
means doing all the domestic labor men
and women are meant to have rigidly
distinct roles in the home in their
relationships and crucially in economic
activity so this isn't just about
personal choice or individual
preferences it's advancing a right-wing
political ideology and dressing it up as
a lifestyle
so why is this important three things
these women are often really young in
their twenties and they're preaching the
values of submitting to a husband to an
audience of other young women the Trad
wife Trend doesn't exist in isolation
it's linked to deeply regressive
political and social movements such as
Christian and white nationalism and
anti-feminism feminism is an ideology
which cannot be defended by feminists
it's part of a wider shift of young
people being dissatisfied with
neoliberalism and wanting social change
well she's right about that last Point
not not any of the rest of it but the
last Point anyway but before we flesh
that out uh let's consider a few other
points first you see how stigmatization
is perhaps the left's most common and
useful tool always has been I mean even
as they claim that they want people to
be free to live their lives without
judgment the truth is that they have a
very rigid idea about what sorts of
Lifestyle should be embraced
and the standard is very simple actually
it's not complicated we should celebrate
any and all Lifestyles that would not be
traditionally considered normal okay
that's the one rule so live how you want
just don't be normal
that's why they use a term like Fringe
subculture to describe a housewife in an
apron who would uh you know but they
would never put such a label on a a man
and a wig and a skirt standing up to pee
in the women's restroom he's not part of
a fringe subculture
instead a 25 year old woman with two
kids and a husband baking a casserole
she's The Fringe weirdo the the
degenerate pervert you know it seems for
Lent this year the left is giving up all
morality and common sense but you don't
have to do the same you can choose today
to strengthen your faith in spite of
this broken world through prayer
meditation and fasting join me and
thousands of others on hallow the number
one Christian Prayer app in the U.S as
Christians we're called to abstain from
luxuries during Lent and instead more
deeply embrace our faith how low is here
to help me maintain that promise in a
daily prayer routine with um uh all the
time especially until Easter and it can
help you do the the same download the
app for free at hollow.com Matt Walsh
you can set prayer reminders you can
track your progress along the way as
well if you're not sure where to start
with you can check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible of the Year podcast
available on the hollow app for brief
daily Bible readings and Reflections or
you could pray alongside Mark Wahlberg
Jim Caviezel even some world-class
athletes with Halo you can customize a
personal prayer plan that works for you
listen anywhere you are with
downloadable offline sessions as well
stay rooted in your faith and your
values during the season of Lent get an
exclusive three-month free trial at
hollow.com Matt Walsh that's hello.com
Matt Walsh
now if that same woman was doing all the
same things but happened to actually be
a man then she or he in this case would
be revered as a bold and powerful woman
daring to live her life as she wishes
the problem with the actual real woman
living this way is that she again is
normal and while they shame normalcy as
perverse and they treat perversion as
normal they somehow have succeeded in
convincing many conservatives to not
respond in kind
as we should
so they will openly call stay-at-home
moms a fringe subculture while insisting
that we must never use such language to
describe Lifestyles that are actually
degenerate
and again many conservatives willingly
play along
by with this they willingly play by this
rule
the left accuses the Trad wife of
engaging in a political Act
but the truth is that you know what
they're really angry about is they're
angry
that she isn't engaging in a political
Act
she's simply living in a way that is
healthy and traditional and she's
prioritizing her family
she she is not turning her entire
existence into a political statement she
is focused on things deeper and more
meaningful than that and that is what
infuriates them
remember that these are people who've
structured their whole lives around
opposing Traditional Values they they
they're not even pursuing happiness or
fulfillment or meaning they'll settle
for misery so long as their misery is a
protest against the value systems they
despise
except that ultimately their misery only
confirms and supports that very same
value system
and that's where the woman in the video
had it right I think people are deeply
dissatisfied with the life that leftism
has given them these uh so-called Trad
wives they grew up in a society that
told them that men and women are the
same that we ought to have exactly
identical roles in society that it's
demeaning it's oppressive to prioritize
raising children and caring for your
family that fulfillment is found in
serving your boss rather than your
spouse that a strong an independent
woman is one who depends on her employer
rather than her husband
they were raised in a culture that takes
all of these ideas for granted
they were socialized and conditioned to
accept them as gospel truth and many of
them did for a Time
and then discovered that it was all a
lie
you know the most basic problem with
leftism is that it is just Hollow at its
core
it doesn't have an answer or at least
not a satisfying answer
to the question of of why we're here on
this Earth and what we're supposed to be
doing with our time
this um
ambiguity this lack of answers is
presented to us as freedom
but it's the freedom of being lost in
the woods the freedom of having no idea
where to go or why
that's not Freedom that's abandonment
this is what has happened so multiple
generations of Americans they've been
brought down a path with uh Promises of
happiness and fulfillment around the
corner and then they were just left
there abandoned
this is this is the the source of much
of the uh you know the epidemic of
Despair what we now call depression in
our society it stems from this not from
Mental Illness but from this
that you have generally of millions of
Americans that were LED down a path they
said well come this way don't go that
way okay that's the way that all of your
ancestors went that's the way that
people for for uh for thousands of years
went uh don't go that way come this way
instead
and all these people listen they said
okay I'll go that way
and then one day they looked around they
said well where are we exactly what's
the point of this where were you taking
us
we're just lost here now we're stuck
so the people who are returning to
traditional Lives who are making the
radical decision to focus on their
families and their marriages and and so
on
um these are people simply deciding to
live with some sense of direction
to live with meaning
okay that's what they're doing they're
not making some white supremacist
radical political statement they are
reclaiming meaning in their lives
and they are certainly happier for it
that'll do it for this portion of the
shows move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not talk to you
on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]